[Aplausos]
la vida en las grandes ciudades
la sobre información en los medios
el permanente estado de tensión en el
que vivimos
así que nuestra vida de pronto se genere
un importante
malestar
y a esto le llamamos actualmente estrés
el estrés por crecer y tener más el
estrés por ser a lo mejor diferentes a
los otros pero esto conlleva grandes
grandes costos
quienes de ustedes piensan que nuestra
mente influye en nuestro estado de salud
o de enfermedad
todos guau
qué maravilla es que ustedes saben que
es un pensamiento una idea bastante
nueva aquí en occidente y esto es muy
importante porque hace como para que los
médicos los psicólogos tengan en cuenta
para que sus pacientes también mejoren
el estado de salud dado que hoy hay
otras tipos de técnicas de disciplinas
complementarias holística
cuando era pequeña tal vez no tanto
me encantaba que todo el mundo estuviera
feliz que todos disfrutaran y me gustaba
ayudar amiguitos a los abuelos a mis
padres
en mi juventud eso se potenció
y así es como me recibí de maestra luego
de médica lo único que quería era seguir
ayudando a la gente a que se sintieran
mejor a que estuvieran disfrutando de la
vida
viaje a canadá recibí cuatro años allá
y cuando regrese me especialicé en
reumatología hermosa disciplina
ejercido durante 10 años en el hospital
francés miles y miles de pacientes
fueron asistidos
y ellos fueron los que me enseñaron que
la enfermedad era el producto de un
impacto emocional muy importante como
puede ser la pérdida de un ser querido
la pérdida de trabajo
un divorcio un accidente un robo
ellos me enseñaron muchísimo
y a través de eso
simplemente distintas
pensamientos porque sinceramente no
sabía cómo ejercer la medicina sentía
que me quedaba que me faltaban cosas
hace 30 años 44 que me recibí pero más
de 30 que me empecé a buscar distintas
disciplinas que me pudieran ayudar y que
pudieran ayudar a la gente que me
consultara
y en ese momento no se hablaba ni de
chico bioenergía
ni de reiki o imposición de manos
pensamientos creativos
de medicina solísticas acá no sucedía
acá en argentina en esta parte de
occidente un día llega al hospital una
paciente que refiere viene doblada
literalmente en dos road doblada
verla solo significaba decirle el
diagnóstico o darle el diagnóstico de
lumbociatalgia aguda
entonces le hago el estudio clínico y
hago las preguntas correspondientes los
antecedentes familiares personales y
entre ellas la que siempre les hacía
todos mis pacientes era que éste sucedió
en los últimos dos años de tu vida hasta
ahora
esta paciente me dice
tengo un hijo drogadicto de 14 años le
roba a mi madre me roba a mí ya no sé
qué hacer
esta mujer ya no podía seguir adelante
estaba paralizada
yo en ese momento podía darle
antiinflamatorios analgésicos fisio
kinesioterapia
y la consulta con un especialista o un
psicólogo
también me sentí
limitada y me faltaban herramientas
esto hizo que me pusiera a investigar
para eso como acá no tenía material de
lo que creía que estaba buscando viaje
todas las veces que podía viajaba y así
conseguir libros en inglés que me
enseñaban distintas técnicas holísticas
diferentes y cómo aportaban para el
estado de salud complementaban hoy le
llamamos holística son complementarias
en esos viajes que hacía conocí a
chamanes médicos de distintas
disciplinas psicólogos psiquiatras geo
biólogos ingenieros
y así aprendí con un grupo de
hipnoterapeuta
que eran enviados especialmente a los
contextos de guerra
porque ellos se enseñaban a niños y
ancianos a proteger su psiquis de los
traumas de la guerra
esto cambió mi vida y también cambió la
forma de ejercer la medicina
y de sentir la medicina ortodoxa que
estaba haciendo
entonces simplemente
distintas disciplinas las que había ido
aprendiendo conociendo a lo largo de
todos estos años entre ellas hipnosis
clínica ericksoniana
la imposición de manos geobiología
visualizaciones creativas y curativas
jackson
y regresión a vidas pasadas entre otras
meditación
la respiración es fundamental la
respiración consciente
también implemente grupos de vivir en
salud el proyecto que desarrollé fue
vivir en salud sin descuidar a los que
enferman
entonces en ellos en los talleres
aprendí y también con los consultantes
aprendí como la vida de pronto las
personas hacían
de una mejor forma de ver la vida
estaban más activos se sentían mejor
tenían mejor ánimo y los que tenían
dolores les calmaban los dolores
voy a vamos a ver como en la práctica es
desde la medicina ortodoxa y luego vemos
desde la medicina holística y las
técnicas holísticas por ejemplo viene un
hombre de 40 años con un dolor
precordial un dolor en el pecho
taquicardias cervical dolores en la
espalda en la columna cervical
consulte al médico
le preocupa sobre todo hay hay edades
que preocupan mucho más a las personas
entonces este hombre va al médico le
hace los antecedentes personales
antecedentes familiares
lo revisa lo oculta le toma la presión
arterial
y
le manda análisis de laboratorio y
electrocardiograma
en la segunda consulta no habiendo una
causa una enfermedad física aparente le
sugiere que es estrés
estrés
le dice bueno deberías buscar alguna
disciplina complementaria algo que te
ayude a relajarte a disminuir el dolor
desde la práctica holística
una de las cosas importantes que tenemos
muy en cuenta es
intentar un plan para cambiar los
hábitos dañinos
hacemos también el estudio clínico
hacemos el interrogatorio con respecto a
los antecedentes familiares y personales
pero ponemos hincapié en qué es lo que
sucedió en los últimos años algo
relevante que le haya sucedido
yo creo que en el 99
por ciento de los casos había un factor
desencadenante de ese dolor de esa
precordial hja de ese malestar y de ese
miedo también
entonces ya desde la primera entrevista
lo que hacemos es respiración consciente
la respiración consciente es algo que
para mí es exprime un sí es mágica
porque porque al respirar
conscientemente eliminamos toxinas de
nuestro cuerpo
y estamos ingresando en el torrente
sanguíneo
todas esas hormonas de bienestar la
serotonina las endorfinas
además calme el dolor
y serena
otra de las cosas que podemos hacer es
limpiar los campos de energía porque
porque nosotros estamos en contacto
durante el día con personas o estamos
manejando o en un colectivo y esto hace
que nuestros campos energético sufra un
poquito de desbalance entonces hacemos
una limpieza del campo energético para
armonizarlo seguimos con una sesión de
reiki que es también un armonizador y
finalizamos con una
frase que tenga pensamientos positivos
pensamientos de bienestar
de amor de serenidad de paz interior
los pensamientos negativos la rumiación
constante el enojo la ira
todo eso va dañando no solamente a
nuestro estado mental sino al cuerpo con
el paso del tiempo
entonces
tenemos que poner en práctica los
pensamientos positivos porque por lo que
están leyendo ahora los pensamientos
negativos lo que hacen es inhibir al
sistema de defensa del sistema
inmunológico durante horas fíjense el
tiempo entonces
que nosotros a lo mejor por algo que nos
sucedió
pensábamos si pensamos negativamente
esto nos puede llegar a destruir
el tesoro está dentro nuestro
eso es así cambio los pensamientos
negativos destructivos la rumiación
constante
por pensamientos positivos
y esto va mejorando el estado de salud
la sensación de
bienestar que podemos llegar a tener
el tesoro está dentro nuestro por qué
porque es algo tan maravilloso y ustedes
lo van a entender saben por qué porque
lo tenemos que poner en práctica pero
desde donde desde nosotros mismos es un
trabajo interior
es un trabajo personal e indelegable no
hay nadie que lo pueda hacer por ustedes
por cada uno de nosotros pero tiene
grandes beneficios otorga grandes
beneficios lo he visto en la práctica y
lo olvido lo veo también en mi vida
personal
cuando deseo mejorar el estado de salud
que es lo que hago activo un diálogo
interno con mi mente consciente
entonces este diálogo debe ser preciso
claro definido con confianza con
tenacidad y determinación
[Aplausos]